a wooden block kept on a table exerts a
force on it and we know that the wooden
block is a solid substance what about
liquids we know that liquids are kept in
containers do liquids or fluids exert
pressure yes they do they exert pressure
on the base and the walls of the
container in which they are enclosed the
pressure on the base will be downwards
and on the walls the pressure will be
side words we can also derive something
interesting if we look at the fluid in
terms of layers then there's water kept
in a plastic container let's divide the
fluid into five equal parts you can see
that the second layer of water is
holding the weight of the first layer
similarly the third layer is holding the
weight of the first as well as the
second layer and the fourth layer is
holding the weight of the top three
layers and so on and so forth
so clearly the pressure at the bottom
most layer is the maximum there's even a
way you can find this out near the
topmost layer make a little hole other
side you'll see that the water flows out
from that hole like this it doesn't roll
along the walls it flows out at an angle
now let's make a second hole near the
layer under it you'll see that the water
flows out at a wider angle as compared
to the earlier case we continue to make
holes in the wall and we'll notice that
the water literally squirts out this
proves that the pressure at the bottom
is much more than the pressure at the
topmost layer what about the upward
force exerted by a liquid how do we
understand that we will see that in our
next video
[Music]
you